this is an exciting uh opportunity for
the three of you and an interesting
thing too is this uh
an extension of the way that you would
talk among your family
or is this the way that you do this red
table talk you know people are expecting
a lot of stories is this new or is this
more of like just kind of the way that
you already talk just on camera
well yeah it's it's absolutely real i
mean
what we discovered doing this thing was
that
there were a lot of things that we
hadn't really discussed because it
wasn't just the three of us
in any one spot now if there were the
three of us then you're going to see
exactly
how the dynamic is well plus a referee
because if it would have been left to
our own devices we've been there six
more hours
and it would have been a lot louder no
absolutely but yes you're gonna get a
lot of stories and
truth because that's what other reason
is there to do this and to
bear our souls unless it's gonna be to
try to connect more with people
and and let them know us a little
further and deeper and also
help in whatever way we can right flat
it is yeah
sexuality for example that that episode
i was there are you pointing to me
and i think from that episode i learned
to like hug the table right yes
you fondled the table yeah i don't know
oh my god we're doing this this is real
okay let's talk about it yes
yeah there were some moments there that
you know we're family we've been
together forever we vacation together
we um you lived in my house i
lived in your home when you came from
cuba a year now
i was there the day you were born like
anything that you asked you know we've
done it
so when something like this comes up
it's kind of hard for the three of us
because we realized like gloria said
there were a lot of things that we
didn't talk about before
and uh and yes you know we got emotional
you know we got
everything happened on that day exactly
as you'll see
yeah is there anything that was uh you
know
not just embarrassing but even kind of
difficult to talk about
given that you are family but sometimes
even with family
you know it's difficult to approach
certain subjects
absolutely and that's one of the reasons
that we really wanted to do this because
in every household that thing but
particularly latin households
there are a lot of topics that are just
not spoken about you know
they you go on like you know life goes
on and everybody is loved and accepted
but you don't talk about them
lily's for example we've never talked
about the very
public divorce that lily went through
that's our first
show and i think we chose it purposely
yeah because we wanted things to be
really personal in those first few shows
and yeah we spoke about things that she
wouldn't have been able to speak about
before emotionally
and likewise for emily and i we're just
dove deep you know i i learned things
about your accident
and about your relationship with dad and
our relationship with each other
you know i think we will definitely be
changed from the table
um but also in addition to trying to
help people
um trying to have a platform so that
peop young people and old people and
whoever needs can see themselves
in the content because obviously we're
in the entertainment industry
you know it's been like that for a long
time but we're all human beings so we
need to
join us together more and not separate
us which is why we're so excited that
it's going to be on facebook watch
because
it's global everyone has access to it
and that's the message that we're trying
to send out
listen emily sounds great but she she
had a feet when i asked gloria
how was that after the accident oh my
god okay mama and you keep bringing it
exactly as if one scar isn't enough
she's like
i didn't want to hear it do you want to
hear about my sex life
okay that's one thing we didn't talk
about the topic before right so exactly
that wouldn't let us like share any
information before
we did the show keep it fresh so yeah we
had a word that's different
we picked exactly right well yes she's
esther fun
fun she's
now i'm mispronouncing my own last name
exactly it's different
but yeah we you know there were is
i've even forgotten now with this jury's
out on the pronunciation
it doesn't matter but yeah there were
some
they they chose the word pineapple to
throw at us every time we were talking
too much about something
and when we had the meetings before we'd
get into it and they go pineapple
pineapple
meaning shut up stop talking so yeah but
we do
we talked about a lot of things that
we've never spoken about
ever so how did this start how did this
opportunity come up for you
well uh jada and um
ellen rackettan and westbrook
productions
which funny enough westbrook westbrook
was the name i used to use to check into
hotels when i was on tour how funny is
that a very strange
coincidence but anyway they had created
this monster
show uh that really broke all molds i
think it's the first of its kind really
on facebook watch and we were fans
and all of a sudden they approached us
with the idea
this was a couple years ago when this
happened yes
and we were out in la doing something
and they met with us and
i don't think you were there but they
pitched the idea of the three of us
and i thought oh my god this is a
no-brainer
this is really a fantastic opportunity
to
first of all secretly for me to spend
more time
with the family that's the real reason
it's a real reason
on to a table for hours on exactly and
she has a gavel
exactly we've actually had a great time
you know like uh trying to put together
uh
topics um i don't know i guess like
also after we did the show just talking
about oh my god
how come we never talked about this
before
the production yeah yeah we're gonna do
another one under the red tape
emily what have you learned about your
mom and about these ladies that you
were surprised by when you started doing
the red table talk
other than they talk too much about
their sex lives on the table
i'm kidding i'm kidding uh i mean i they
they're my role models my whole life
you know so it's really hard for
something to surprise me and it did
because i think we surprised each other
we brought out
uh you know a kind of quality and an
honesty that's usually you're trained
to keep off of camera which is not
really a good thing and i think why
jada's was uh as unique
as it was and we also focus on theirs
it's not only jada's
you know all of their scammy yeah of
course
um led by their example as well
you know so i learned i think we all
learned stuff about each other oh yes
i learned that their strength that i
thought they had was really only the tip
of the iceberg
and um yeah i think reflecting on it and
watching back now is when i'm really
going to be able to
you know who i learned a lot a lot from
believe it or not lily's uh daughter
yes who made an appearance and blew me
away
grew up before my eyes and then came out
like a prophet and shut us all down
for real though it's a yeah that was
that was a highlight for me she uh
she's incredible yeah i the first
episode
it's a divorce we're coming out with
divorce which is a very personal to me
and uh we all came to the table as a
family it's kind of like the perspective
of
how difficult is for not only the person
and you know just children husband and
wife
how the extended family you know how
hard it is for them
to try to keep it together when
everything is just falling apart
so emilia was you know went to the table
because yeah
uh he was involved you know uh he
he found out you know before i did
exactly and then you know my daughter
who also
blew us away yeah and found out before
but
yeah i can't you see with the whole
pineapple but
it's a whole pie so
uh not sliced yeah so the first episode
you're gonna see the whole family
uh things that we really couldn't
i think we couldn't talk about this
before it's like you say whatever no one
was ready because it's been a process
it was not only the divorce but the
family yeah you know
we chose very personal topics for the
first few
not that they're not all because they
really are all but
my sister makes an appearance on a
couple of the shows
uh we have some big guests rosie
o'donnell
michelle rodriguez de castillo le level
but and a lot that we still haven't
announced but it we
we also brought on experts uh when we
talked about the grief episode we wanted
to offer
you know things that people could trust
suggestions and things so
here's the world expert on on grief
and uh matt mouser who
lost his wife uh on the helicopter with
kobe bryant and was left with three kids
so people that are really going through
it and our own personal stories with
grief we chose things
that everyone can identify at some point
in their lives
with the topics that we're going to talk
about yeah
now gloria teaming up with jada must
have been i mean you said that you're a
fan of the show so it must have been a
dream come true to be able to do that
um she is a powerful opinionated person
and i think it's been interesting seeing
her navigate the truth that she reveals
to the world
and then the world's reactions to what
you know
her and her family have gone through
themselves did the two of you talk about
how to do that if you know if the
reaction to the things that you're
saying
is unexpected or uh just
if people are intrigued by things that
you might not have
anticipated exactly well that's a very
interesting topic we didn't really talk
about it because
i think that we are all very much aware
i mean we've lived our lives in
entertainment emily just came into it
recently but not really yeah i mean i
grew up
entertaining yeah yeah but i mean like
with you guys
with what happens whenever you share
something
i think they're very better versed than
us
because of social media they've grown up
in an era where
everybody has an opinion about anything
they post
i look at it in a different way i
studied communication super interesting
to me i watch it
very carefully because it's both a
blessing and a curse
and lily does a daily talk show so
people react
instantly on her instagram whenever
anything gets
sad that they like or don't like so
we're aware of that part of it
and you do take a risk whenever you do
anything of this nature but
anything that you've got no glory
exactly any art form any time you write
a song
people are going to opine one way or the
other every time i wear my hair curly or
straight
people have an opinion regardless
whatever their opinion is
we're coming from such an honest place
that i welcome any opinion
good or bad as long as there's one
person that this helped it'll all be
worth it
you